foreign
data is getting bigger day by day and it
has a significant role in decision
making for companies now in order to
handle these huge amounts of data there
is a need for database and database
Management Systems now in order to
communicate with these databases you
need a tool this is where SQL comes into
picture would you like to Ace the most
frequently Asked SQL interview questions
during your campus placements to land in
your dream company well you are at the
right place and on that note hello
everyone welcome to Simply learns
YouTube channel I hope you guys are
doing well and staying safe in this
tutorial we will be taking you through
some most commonly asked SQL interview
questions in 2022 and for 2023 we look
at some of the key things that you need
to keep in mind while answering these
interview questions the general
questions will revolve around key
Concepts like commands constraints joins
functions transactions and other
database related questions you may also
get some scenario your based questions
wherein the interviewer might ask you to
write queries other than the theoretical
questions wherein the interviewer wants
to test your knowledge in depth so we'll
be going through all these
technicalities and see how to answer
these questions in your next interview
but before we begin if you're new to the
channel and haven't subscribed already
consider getting subscribed to our
Channel simply learn to stay updated
with all the latest tech content and hit
that Bell icon to never miss an update
from us so without any further Ado let's
get started
so the first question is what is SQL and
why it is used SQL or structured query
language refers to a standard
programming language utilized to extract
organize manage and manipulate data
stored in relational databases SQL is
thereby referred to as a database
language that can execute activities on
databases that consist of tables made up
of rows and columns SQL commands are
used to process analyze and manipulate
the data that is stored in databases SQL
plays a crucial role in retrieving
relevant data from databases by
performing various operations like
insertion updation modification and
deletion
SQL can manage several data transactions
simultaneously where large volumes of
data are written concurrently so that is
SQL and why it is used
moving ahead let us now discuss our next
question which is why we need a database
as the technology kept on advancing the
file system had became difficult to
handle when the number of files
increased and the volume of data also
grew this is where database comes into
picture the system is no longer able to
store and retrieve data efficiently and
this created some some limitations and
drawbacks and that is when we needed a
new medium through databases now the
problem with traditional file systems is
we have data redundancy and
inconsistency redundancy means when the
same data is getting duplicated and
repeated in different location this
leads to excess and unwanted storage
which eventually results in
inconsistency where the data in
different files does not match with each
other data isolation data is isolated
because it is scattered in various files
in different locations and the files may
be in different formats as well at any
point writing new application programs
to retrieve the appropriate data becomes
difficult as the files are separated
from each other in different locations
limited data access file storage systems
usually do not have access for multiple
users this means multiple users at
different places cannot access the data
simultaneously it becomes difficult to
access important data if multiple users
are searching at the same time
security and integrity issues
data is of Paramount importance to
anyone and its privacy and its security
is one of the most important things we
need to consider data stored in files
can be easily accessed and tampered so
it is important to prevent access to
unauthorized users to hold the Integrity
of the stored data so in order to
eliminate all these drawbacks we use a
database which is further controlled by
a database management system
all right moving ahead the next question
is how does an SQL database works now
database store related information
across multiple tables and allows you to
query information using SQL commands but
the process it is a bit of
a hectic one and in order to understand
this in a simple way I have put a flow
diagram here where you can understand
how the flow between the user and the
SQL engine through the database server
is happening now a typical SQL database
engine includes a storage engine which
is a database server and the query
processor within the SQL engine now to
retrieve the data the query processor in
the SQL engine accepts and executes SQL
commands for the database server which
forwards to an application server now
this application server within the
database process the SQL request and
sets it to a web server where the user
can access the information via SQL
cables if the required data is found in
the tables that is present in the
database server it sends the information
back to the user in this way one can
find the the data that is needed from
the database by writing simple SQL
queries so this is how a traditional SQL
database works I hope you guys have
understood let us now move ahead and
discuss the next question which is what
are the main usages of SQL or you might
be asked what are the features of SQL or
you can or you might be asked why we use
SQL now SQL is responsible for accessing
and manipulating the data present in
databases by writing simple SQL queries
now the main function or the main usages
of SQL is it is used to execute query
against a database Now by writing a
simple query you can perform complex
operations to retrieve data from the
database you can also perform various
operations like insert update and delete
records for example if you have created
a new table you can insert records in
that now due to for due to some reasons
if there is a modification or a change
in the record you can use the update
statement to modify them and finally if
you no longer want to process that data
or show the data in that table you can
use the delete command to delete that
data present in that table
and again as discussed earlier it is
used to perform complex operations on
the database like functions by joining
two or more tables and Etc
the next question is what do you
understand by tables and Fields in a
database
a table is a set of data that is
organized in a model in the columns and
rows format tables are considered as the
fundamental level to store data in a
relational database management system it
contains a header row at the top of the
table which gives the list of column
names
now the tables contain rows and columns
where the rows are known as records in
general and the columns are known as
Fields now a column is set of data
values of a particular type like numbers
or alphabets for example if you consider
the employee table here which has
employee ID employee name job department
number salary in the column names which
is basically considered as the different
fields and we also have different
records present in this table like if
you consider the employee details of
Rohan whose employee ID is 1011 who is
working as a data analyst so fields are
basically columns in a table with
specific information about the data and
a record is basically an individual
entry that exists in a table
all right the next question is explain
different types of commands in SQL now
mainly there are four types of commands
in SQL the first one is data definition
language or ddl data destination
language helps you to define the
database structure or schema
data manipulation language or DML DML
allows you to modify the database
instance by inserting modifying and
deleting its data
next we have data control language or
DCL DCL gives access to the data stored
in the database by granting and revoking
permissions to the user and finally we
have transaction control language or TCL
TCL commands deal with the transactions
within the database so these were some
of the important and mainly used SQL
commands
now moving ahead you might be asked to
explain any one of the SQL commands in
detail so I have taken other question
here which states that what are the
statements used under DML commands so
you need to prepare accordingly and
thoroughly so that interviewer want to
know whether you have the in-depth
knowledge of the SQL commands or not now
typically under DML commands we have
four statements the first one is Select
this command is used to fetch data from
a database table next we have insert
insert is is used to insert data into a
table of a database now if you have
created a database and if you want to
insert some record into it you can use
the insert statement next we have update
update command allows modifying a data
in the table now as discussed earlier if
you want to make changes in your
database you can use the update
statement which basically updates the
value in a given table and finally we
have delete this command allows deleting
specific rows from the table now if a
longer if you no longer want the data to
be present in your table in that case
you can use the delete statement now
guys we have select statement which also
comes under dql command which is data
query language but in most of the cases
we consider it under DML command as well
so you need not worry so these are the
four statements that come under DML
commands moving ahead the next question
is what are aggregate functions in SQL
aggregate function SQL perform a
calculation on multiple values and
return a single value
now we have five different types of
aggregate functions in SQL the first one
is Count function count is used to
basically count the total number of
fields or number of uh data that you
want from your table next we have the
average average is used to calculate the
average of all the fields that are
present in the table
next we have minimum and maximum as the
name suggests they are used to find the
maximum and minimum value while
performing any complex or mathematical
calculations from your table and finally
we have sum which is used to summarize
or calculate the whole of the values
that are present in the table so these
are some aggregate functions that are
used in SQL
the next question is what are
constraints in SQL constraints are a set
of rules imposed on tables of relational
databases constraints help in
maintaining the accuracy integrity and
reliability of a database
now we have total of six types of
constraints that are present in SQL the
first one is unique unique constraint
ensures that all the values in a column
are different
primary key primary key is a combination
of a not null and unique constraint
which basically uniquely identifies each
row in a table
next we have foreign key foreign key
uniquely identifies a row or record in
an other table
next we have default constraint default
constraint sets a default value for a
column when no value is specified so if
you're working on a database and if you
haven't assigned a value in to that
record it will automatically give a
default value
next we have check constraint check
basically ensures that all the values in
a column satisfies a specific condition
and finally we have not null not null
ensures that a column cannot have a null
value so that was all about constraints
and the different types of constraints
that we use in SQL
next question is what are keys in SQL
and why do we use them SQL key is an
attribute or set of attributes which
help you to identify a unique row in a
table
SQL case are one of the most important
attributes of any relational database
because it plays important role to
establish a relationship between two or
more tables it also helps queries to
execute faster that is retrieval of the
records from the database becomes much
faster by using keys keys also set the
different constraint to uniquely
identify the tuples or rows from the
large data sets
all right now once you are as water Keys
the interviewer might ask what are
different types of keys used in SQL so
you have to be prepared for that as well
now in general we have four different
types of keys present in SQL the first
one is primary key the primary key in
SQL is a single or a group of fields or
columns that can uniquely identify a row
in a table for example employee ID or
student ID in a table is considered as a
primary key because it uniquely
identifies each and every record present
in that table next we have super key a
Super Key is a combination of all
possible attributes which can uniquely
identify rows or tuples in a table
next we have candidate key candidate key
can be defined as a set of one or more
columns that can identify or record or a
tuple uniquely in a table
foreign key a foreign key is a set of
attributes in a table that refers to the
primary key of another table so if you
want to connect another table using the
primary key of the existing table then
the key that is present in the uh new
table is considered as the foreign key
now for candidate key let's say I have
different uh you know Fields like let's
say aadhar card passport or driving
license as Fields present in my table so
which can uniquely identify or record
uniquely similar to that of primary key
now since candidate key is a set of one
or more columns we consider all these
all of them as candidate keys so I hope
you've understood till now uh what are
the different types of keys used in SQL
all right moving ahead let us now
discuss the next question which is what
are some common Clauses used with select
query in SQL now as we know SQL being a
query language requires a method to
apply constraints on the data and for
that we use Clauses skill Clauses are
basically inbuilt SQL functions which
allows us to apply certain restrictions
on the data in a resultant set now with
the help of SQL Clauses we can filter
the data according to our requirement
and it also reduces the complexity of a
query which helps in writing
user-friendly queries which are easy to
read and understand as well which also
ultimately allows us to restrict the
number of outputs or the certain amount
of data that we want in our resultant
set now let us now discuss some of the
different types of Clauses used in SQL
first we have where plus it is used to
filter records in the database now as
you all know familiar that we have like
thousands and thousands of Records in
our you know database so if you want to
filter only a particular records as per
your requirement then you can give a
condition which can be done by using a
where Clause next we have ordered by
order by Source the data either in
ascending or descending order next we
have group by Group by is used to group
entries with identical data and can be
used with aggregation functions or
methods to obtain summarized database
results next we have having Clause
having Clause basically filters the rows
where aggregate values may be specified
conditions now Group by and having are
almost similar to each other so you can
consider both of them to filter the
records as per your requirement next we
have the limit and again as the name
suggests it is used to restrict the
number of results from the query or the
result in the resultant set for example
if you have hundreds hundred records in
your database and if you want only 50
requests to display in a resultant set
then in that case you can use them limit
and finally we have the distinct clause
which is used to you know discard the
rows having any duplicate values which
basically eliminates you know certain
records that have any duplicate value so
if there are any records that are
repeated in your table then you can
eliminate them by using distance plus so
those are some of the common Clauses
that we use with select query
all right let us now discuss the next
question which is what is the difference
between care and wire care data types
now I know you've all used both these
you know data types extensively while
working on your database but due to how
frequently we use them many of us fail
to recognize their differences when
asked to choose between worker and Care
in your interview questions now the
difference is important to know from
both an interview point of view and from
the standpoint of the database design as
well when you're working on your you
know database application because uh a
poor choice of data type from both these
uh you know data types restricts the
type of data you can add which can
ultimately waste space and slow down
your query as well so it is important
that we understand the difference now
first difference between them is care is
a fixed length character string data
type and wirecare is a variable in
character string data type
and coming to care this data type can be
a single byte or a multiple byte whereas
wire can accept character strings up to
only 255 bytes now character or care
data type can be used when the character
length is known so if you're working or
if you are specifying a column data type
wherein you know the length of the
character in such case you can use the
cat whereas on the other side wire car
is a data type which is used when the
character length is not clear so for a
string values when the total number of
character length is not known in such
case you have to take VAR Care Now care
is used when the character length of the
data is the same whereas worker is used
when the character length of the data is
changing that is when it is variable and
finally car is a static data type and
badcad is a dynamic data type so these
are some of the main and important
difference between carrot and wire care
data types and choosing between them uh
is important that because you know it
can ultimately affect your database
performance so it is important to choose
the right data type
all right moving ahead the next question
is name few data types used in SQL I
hope you've come across this word data
type in almost every programming
languages so similar to those uh data
types present in unlike any other
programming languages we do have certain
data types which are similar in SQL as
well now as we know a data tape a
database table must have a name and data
type for each column so when building a
table an SQL Developer must decide what
kind of data will be stored in each
column so the data specifies how SQL
will interact with the store data and
serves as a guide for SQL engine and
determining what kind of data is
expected inside of each column so we
have different data types like numeric
data type which has in type bit float
and Boolean types of uh you know
elements of data types next we have
string data type which contains care
worker and Text data types and next we
also have date time data types which
takes a different elements again which
has date format which only takes the
entry of date in year month rate we also
have date time we also have time stamp
as well now other than this we have some
miscellaneous and extra data types also
for example XML and Json formats in
order to store the data in our tables as
well so these are some of the important
data types used in SQL I hope you guys
have understood
all right moving ahead let us now
discuss the next question which is
explain the difference between Group by
and order by now both these Clauses are
one of the important Clauses in SQL as
they are used to filter and sort the
data as per our requirement so it is
also again important that how we use
them and how their uh you know
specifically being used is important so
you have to understand the differences
and when to use and when not to use now
coming to group by Group by is used to
group the rows that have the same value
whereas order by is used to arrange the
data obtained as a result of a query in
a sorted form so let's say if you want
to arrange the first 10 records in
ascending order then you can use the
order byte Clause whereas if you are
let's say want to group certain columns
in a particular order so then in that in
that case you can use Group by Group by
Clause now group I always is used before
the order by clause in the select
statement whereas order by is used after
the group by clause in a select state
so if you want to use a group by you
need to use before the order by and
similarly for uh order by also it is you
always used after the group by next
Group by uh attributes under aggregation
function cannot be in group by Clause
whereas attributes under aggregate
functions can be in order by Clause now
it is also mandatory to use aggregate
functions in the group by so whenever
you are performing function aggregate
functions like count sum average minimum
and maximum in such case you need Group
by whereas aggregate function is not
compulsory as such to use an order by
function and finally the important thing
Group by controls the presentation of
rows or tuples whereas order by controls
the presentation of columns
all right moving ahead let us now
discuss the next question which is why
do we use case statement in SQL
so the case statement in SQL is a way of
handling the if else statement that we
use uh in other programming languages
which basically uh returns a value for
the condition specified now it tests a
list of conditions and returns one of
the multiple possible results so it is
used to fetch us a particular value
based on a certain condition in your
database so the case expression
basically goes through conditions and
return of value then the first condition
is met just like an if then else
statement so once a condition is true it
will stop reading and return the result
if no conditions are true it Returns the
value in the else clause and if there is
no else part and no conditions are true
it will basically return a null value so
that is what an SQL case statement does
in your SQL database so for example if
you consider an example here we have a
query such as select employee ID job
title salary and we have to mention the
keyword case and it is always followed
with a when and then keyword so I am
specifying a condition here when salary
is greater than or equals to 50 000 I
want to display a string value that is
the salary is greater than 50 000 and if
salary is equals to 50 000 I want to
display a you know message as the salary
is 50 000 and if both these conditions
are not satisfying then it will go to
the else part which will basically
return the salary is under 50 000 and it
will always end with an end as statement
so this is what case statement is in SQL
and why do we use it
all right moving ahead one of the most
important questions which is what are
joints in a SQL and explain different
types of joints
now you might have come across the SQL
joins key Awards in most of the cases
guys uh they're one of the important
statements in SQL which allows you to
access information from two or more
tables at once which also keep our
database normalized basically
normalization is allows us to keep data
redundancy low so that we can decrease
the amount of data anomalies in our
application when we delete or update a
record we'll get into that uh when we
talk about normalization in detail so
you just have to understand that the
joint laws allows us to retrieve data
from two or more related tables into a
meaningful resultant set
so for example we'll understand with an
example consider a Mercedes Benz which
is one of the uh you know largest
automobile manufacturing companies in
the world so let's say they're trying to
access some information of their
customers now in the database let us
assume that they have three different
tables of customer an order table and a
vehicle table now let's say they're
trying to find a particular model type
you know which a customer has purchased
in a recent time so for that in order to
find that data they have to go through
three different stages that is first
they have to find the customer table and
then they have to go to order table to
find the order ID so that they can get
into the vehicle ID details and finally
they'll fetch the model type or let's
say the the variant from the vehicle
orders now instead of that I'll just
simply join the two tables that is the
customer table and vehicle table based
on the common column that is present in
this both table which is customer ID so
with the help of this common field I can
retrieve the model and the variant
instead of searching the three tables
you know one at a time so simultaneously
I'm able to retrieve data by using
common columns in both the table so that
is one of the most important USB or the
uh factor that a join does when you're
trying to retrieve data from more than
one table
so I hope you've understood what what
joints are and let us now understand the
different types of joints now the first
joint is inner joint
the inner joint returns only those
records that have matching values from
both the tables that is the left table
and right table next we have the outer
or full outer join now
outer join basically retrieves the data
from both the tables irrespective of
whether they are matching or not so it
will display the values either from left
table or from right table
now next we have the left join as the
name suggests the left John gives
priority to the first table or the left
table or the first table so it will
retrieve only the records that are
present in the left table and only the
matching records that are present from
the right table
and finally we have the right join right
join basically retrieves the data from
the right table or the second table and
only the matching values from the left
table or the first table so these are
some different types of joints we use in
SQL if you want to learn more about SQL
joints make sure to check out our SQL
joins tutorial on our Channel where we
have discussed the syntax and its use
cases which with a certain examples and
its execution in MySQL workbench as well
so I would highly recommend you to check
that out
all right moving ahead next question is
what is explain the difference between a
join and a union in SQL
so now joints and unions can be used to
combine data from one or more tables now
the difference lies in how the data is
combined so in simple terms joins
combine data into new columns if two
tables are joined together then the data
from the first table is shown in one set
of column alongside the second tables
column in the same row so if you look at
this example where we have taken two
tables in a resultant tables The Columns
are being added side by side
so each row in the result uh contains
column from both table A and B rows are
created when columns from one table
match columns from another so this match
is basically called the join condition
but when I speak about Union Union
combines data into new rows in a union
each row within the result is from one
table or the other in a union columns
aren't combined to create results but
rows are combined unions are typically
used when you have two results whose
rows you want to include in the same you
know same result that is if you want to
include the difference the rows in your
resultant set then in that case you have
to choose the union so that that was
some of the main differences between the
join and Union statement
all right moving ahead let us now
discuss the next question which is what
is the difference between delete and
truncate delete command is used to
delete only specified number of rows
that is if you want to delete only
specific rows like one or more rows you
can uh use the delete statement whereas
the truncate command is used to delete
all the rows uh in a single go from a
table delete comes in a DML command that
is data manipulation language whereas
truncate is a ddl command which is data
definition language
now there may be a where clause in the
delete command in order to filter the
records since we are specifying uh
deleting only specifying specified rows
we can use a where Clause to limit the
number of rows that we want to delete
whereas we do not have the option to use
where clause in the truncate command as
it deletes all the rows simultaneously
Now using when you use a delete the
changes can be rolled back so once you
delete certain records from the table
you can use the rollback statement uh to
make changes again whereas if you use
the truncate the changes cannot be
rolled back once you are once you have
deleted the records from the table it
will completely uh just vanish from the
table and you do not have the you know
luxury to get back to to its original
state that is it cannot be rolled back
now delete on a performance side the
latest slower than truncate because they
are individually deleting the rows
whereas truncate is faster than delete
because we are deleting all the rows at
a single time
so these are some of the main
differences between delete and truncate
and one thing you have to keep in mind
in that uh when you are using truncate
you have to be careful because once you
have once if you use the truncate and
once the deletion is done you cannot uh
get back to its original state that is
that changes can be rolled back so it is
very important that you choose these two
statements you know wisely
all right moving ahead let us now
discuss the next question which is what
are sub queries and how they're used in
SQL now software is in SQL are another
important concept if you are trying to
solve complex SQL queries so in such
case sub queries can be quite handful so
you need to know what sub queries are
now as the statement says as an SQL sub
query is nothing but a query inside or
another queries and we use a sub query
to fetch data from more than one table
that is if you're retrieving data from
one or more tables we need sub queries
and a sub query is also often referred
to as an inner query while the statement
containing a sub query is also called an
outer query or outer select statement we
can Implement sub queries with the
select insert update and delete
statements along with the operators like
equals to greater than equals to in
between and Etc now consider an example
here where I'm trying to find you know
the listed price of all the items
present in the orders table whose price
is greater than the average of total
listed price in that order a table so
here the inner query becomes the select
average listed price from the order
table statement so it basically
calculates the result of this in a query
first and it passes on to the outer
query so let's say if I have the average
of the listed price is 100 so the outer
query basically selects the name the
listed price from the orders table whose
listed price is greater than 100 so it
will retrieve all the data whose price
in order table is greater than 100 so in
this way you can use sub queries you
know to find complex or more you know to
find inferences of the complex queries
by using a simple sub query so I hope
you understood what sub queries are
let us now move ahead and discuss the
next question which is what is asset
property in a database now to ensure
that the database is in a consistent
State both before and after the
transaction one needs to follow certain
properties and those properties are
known as asset properties now where a
stands for atomicity C stands for
consistency I stands for isolation and d
stands for durability now talking about
atomicity the concept of automatic
atomicity describes how the data stays
Atomic so in other words if an action or
transaction is performed on the data it
should either be executed completed or
not executed at all
so changes in the data must be like a
single operation now next we have the
consistency consistency the idea behind
consistency is the value must constantly
be maintained now the Integrity of the
data should be upheld in dbms or SQL
which means the changes uh done to the
database should always always be saved
next we have isolation now the
characteristic guarantees that uh
numerous transactions can take
simultaneously without causing the
database state to become inconsistent so
transaction uh takes place without
interruption and independently so
changes made in one transaction are not
visible to changes made in any other
transaction until the change in question
has been committed or not so isolation
basically checks whether the transaction
is getting successful in case of any
system failures or not and finally we
have durability now durability as the
name suggests something which a
transaction done is permanent if it is
durable durability in dbms or SQL refers
to the guarantee that data remains in
the database permanently once an
operation has been successfully
completed so these are the asset
properties that are present in a
database which are also quite useful
when you are working on SQL database
because it should satisfy the condition
uh in the tables that you are working on
all right moving ahead let us now
discuss the next question what are
common table expression in SQL now a CT
or Common Table expression defines a
temporary result set that a user can
refer possibly multiple times within a
SQL statement so if you're serving
someone working on large databases and
if you want to use the queries that have
already created you can just simply make
us comment table expression where in it
enables user to write and maintain the
queries easily with increased
readability and reusability
now cities are more readable than
subquery which makes it and go to uh SQL
statement or the concept now CT
basically increases the performance of
the query now instead of writing the
query each and every time while you're
working on a database you can just
simply already call The Common Table
expression that you have created earlier
now the syntax of CT is written as with
CTE name that is you have to mention the
CT name as within the parenthesis select
column 1 column two from tables and
close the parenthesis and again mention
the select statement column one column
two from CT name that you have written
and you can also mention the condition
using the where clause
so that was about all about the Common
Table expressions in SQL
all right moving ahead let us now
discuss what is normalization in SQL
again guys normalization is a quite
important concept even if you are
working on a dbms or SQL Concepts I
think it is important to prepare uh well
uh for your interviews and this is one
of the important question if you are
preparing for that now a normalization
is basically the process to eliminate
data redundancy and enhance data
Integrity in the table so it basically
uh is useful to you know uh have the
data redundancy and inconsistency at
place it is basically a multi-step
process that step that sets the data in
a tabular form and removes the
duplicated data from the relational
tables so and also we have different
types of normal forms guys so you need
to prepare all of them and interviewer
interviewer might ask you uh one of the
normal forms that is uh present so we
have four different types of normal
forms such as one and f 2 and F3 NF and
P CNF now a following question can be
you know to explain any of the normal
form now I'm considering here what is
first normal form so
for a table to be in first normal form
you know the atomicity of the table is
one that is every table should contain a
single value and each and every record
must be unique now let us understand
with an example here let's say I have a
table of students which has roll number
name age courses as different fields now
as you can see for one student we have
multiple courses present in the same
record so we have for Hersh he has opted
for courses SQL and Java now as per the
first normalization definition it is not
correct because it shouldn't have
multiple values present in one record or
one column so we can this we can
eliminate this by you know converting
into a separate row that is we might
have uh you know repeated values but it
should be unique values so
I have written SQL and Java into
separate table into separate columns in
a resultant table which basically
satisfies the first normal form
all right moving ahead let us now
discuss the next question what is
difference between SQL and MySQL now the
interviewer might want to understand
your you know in-depth knowledge whether
you are understanding you know the
differences between a MySQL which is a
relational database and an SQL which is
a programming language so the difference
is basically SQL is a programming
language whereas MySQL is a relational
database management system which is used
to you know perform various operations
like insert update delete on the data
that is stored in the database
so SQL is a language which is useful in
querying relational database system and
again whereas MySQL is used to store
modify and delete data in a database in
an organized way SQL is a licensed
product of Microsoft whereas MySQL is an
open source platform managed by Oracle
Corporation
SQL provides adequate protection to SQL
servers against Intruders whereas MySQL
being an open source platform we cannot
guarantee the security as it is
unreliable
coming to SQL it doesn't support any
connectors whereas in MySQL we have
various tools such as MySQL workbench in
order to build databases
so these are some of the major
differences between the SQL and MySQL
the next question is write an SQL query
to find second highest salary from
employee table now we all know to find
the highest salary we can simply use the
max you know aggregate function so the
following query would be select ID
employee name maximum of salary from
employee all right but what if you want
to find second highest salary that is
where a sub query comes into picture you
need to use a sub query to First find
select maximum salary from the table and
then you have to retrieve your
particular columns that is employee Name
ID or maximum salary from employee where
salary is less than that maximum salary
so something which is less than the max
would be the second highest rate so that
is what the logic is and we are doing
that simply with use of subqueries here
all right moving ahead let us now
discuss the next question which is
explain the differences between where
and having Clause so where Clause is
used to filter the records from the
table based on specific condition
whereas having flaws is also used to
filter record from the groups based on a
specific condition where Clause can be
used without Group by clause and having
Clause cannot be used without Guru by
Clause where Clause implements in a row
operation whereas having Clause
implements in column operations now in
general where Clause cannot contain
aggregate function whereas in having
Clause you can include various aggregate
functions like count some average
minimum maximum Etc and finally where
Clause can be used with select update
drift statement while you cannot use any
of this statement with having plus where
you can just only use the select
statement
so that were the differences between
where and having Plus
the next question is write an SQL query
to return even and odd number records
from table now I hope you guys know the
logic behind this it is a simple SQL
query you just have to use the model as
operator which Returns the records with
order even values for that we need to
check the reminder when we divide the
column value by 2. so when the reminder
is 0 that is basically an even number
otherwise it's an odd number so the
query for even number records is Select
start from table where ID modulus 2 is
equals to 0 and for odd number odd
number records you need to write a query
as select star from table where ID
modulus 2 not equals to 0.
all right the next question is what is
the difference between a function and
procedure functions and stored procedure
another important concept but their way
of implementation is bit of similar so
but you need to understand the
differences on how they work so function
basically returns a value that is it
should always return a value when you
are writing when you are performing a a
complex function on your data database
table and function can be called from a
select query as well and function is
generally used to perform some
calculation and always return a result
whereas on the other hand start
procedures cannot be used in SQL
statements anywhere in the where having
or Select Plus
procedures can either return a single
multiple or no values at all that is we
have an optional condition here that
procedure may or may not return values
in the resultant set
Now using short procedure we can prepare
SQL code which you can save so that the
code can be reused again and again which
is not with the case of function so
stored procedure can be quite helpful
again if you are working a large data
set and if you want to retrieve uh
values and if you want to fetch data in
that case stored procedure can be quite
useful as you cannot uh you know as you
can use it
simultaneously or multiple times
all right moving ahead let us now
discuss the next question which is how
to create a new table from an existing
table now creating a new table from on
already uh you know created table is a
bit of easy you just have to use uh
we create and select statement so as it
states a copy of a table can be created
from an existing table using the
combination of both create and select
statement and the syntax is create table
mention the new table name as mentioned
the select statement inside the columns
that you want to retrieve from the
already present table that is from the
existing table and you can also mention
the where now if you want only a
particular column in that case you can
use the where condition so that was how
that is how you can create a new table
from an existing table again this is a
simple you know SQL query wherein the
interviewer wants to know if you are you
know having proper knowledge on the
tables like of creating a tables foreign
the next question is how is SQL
different from nosql now you guys might
might have heard about nosql which is
basically trending a lot nowadays where
it is used to store a lot of
unstructured data now as the data is
increasing day by day SQL has been in a
downside where it is unable to store you
know a lot of unstructured data that is
coming from the internet and from the
you know World Wide Web so in that case
you know companies have switched to
another technology which uses a new you
know way of storing the data be it you
know unstructured or semi-structured
data which is nosql however there are
differences between SQL and nosql that
is SQL is a relational database that is
it comprises of rows and columns in a
table and it is only stored in that
format while no SQL is a non-relational
database which basically you know stores
data in a key value pair or a document
based or a graph based data are
structured and while SQL has a fixed
schema design and structure that is you
need to you know give the table
structure that is you need to predefine
this schema that is your rows or your
columns in hindsight whereas noise scale
has a dynamic schema design and
structure that is you need not provide
you know a schema if you're working on
nosql database SQL handles complex
queries whereas nosql handles large
volumes of data so let's say if you have
some data present in your table and if
you are you know constantly working on
it and Performing complex queries in
that case you need SQL to retrieve the
data whereas if you are having large
volumes of data in that case you can use
nosql SQL is vertically scalable while
nosql is horizontally scalable
now from what do I mean scalable is
basically as a term used in database
whereas scalability is the ability to
expand or contract the capacity of
system resources in order to support the
ever-changing usage of your applications
now when I talk about vertical scaling
it refers to increasing the processing
power of a single server or cluster now
both relational as well as the
non-relational database can scale up but
eventually there will be a limit in
terms of Maximum processing power and
throughput whereas the horizontal
scaling also known as the scale out
method refers to Bringing on additional
nodes to set the ring that is you can
even improve you can even add CPUs and
ramps to your existing server now this
is difficult with relational databases
because due to difficulty in spreading
out related data across the nodes but
with non-relational database or with SQL
this is made simpler since collections
which we use in nosql are self-contained
under coupled relationally and finally
SQL follows asset property that we have
already discussed in our previous
question which is what is asset property
and whereas NOS skill follows cap
property
so these were some of the main
difference between you know the
traditional SQL language and the new or
the emerging technology that is no SQL
all right going ahead the next question
is write an SQL query to find the nth
highest salary from a table now if
you're a beginner or someone working as
an SQL Developer even to an intermediate
level uh finding you know first second
third highest salary can be quite easy
you know using you know sub queries or
functions but whereas to find the nth
highest salary you need a bit of more of
assistance so using a sub query you can
find the inside a higher salary wherein
the query is written as select salary
from employees as employee one where n
minus 1. now here n basically denotes
the higher and higher salary that you
want to calculate let's say if I want to
find the 35th highest salary you need to
mention 35 in the end Place equals to
select count distinct salary from
employees as employee to I'm giving an
alias name here where employee 2. salary
is greater than employee one dot salary
now
the logic behind this is a basically
self joining the same table again and
I'm comparing the two tables wherein it
will compare the salary from the second
table which is greater than the first
salary and it will retrieve the data in
the resultant set now you can use this
or do this in another way using the
limit Clause the query is written as
select star from employees where salary
is equals to select distinct salary from
employees order by salary limit n comma
1. now this is applicable in most of the
databases that you're working on like
MySQL SQL server or even Oracle as well
where you just have to specify the N
value and use a limit clause and it will
do the rest
so let's say if I want to find uh 50th
highest salary in place of n i can
basically put 50 also and we can also
find the nth higher salary using the row
number function now if you want to know
in detail on how to use the row number
function and the syntax of it you can
check out our video uh on how to find
highest salary from our from a table in
our Channel where we have discussed
clearly on how to use various different
methods and especially how to use the
row number function as well so I'd
highly recommend you guys to check that
out
all right moving ahead the next question
is name the operator which is used for
pattern matching in SQL now SQL like
command or operator is is used to find a
specific character in our database so it
basically determines whether a specific
character that you are mentioning
matches a pattern string or not now this
is used to perform complex pattern
search in data wherein you don't know
the uh you know complete you know
information that you are working on the
data so
just with the help of some certain
specifics or specific characters that
I'm talking here about uh you can
basically retrieve the data the syntax
is followed as select column one column
two column in from table name where
column name like pattern let us just
understand this an example where again
you can have a follow-up question for
this where it is where the interviewer
can ask you write an SQL query to fetch
the employees whose name begins with any
two characters followed by a text R A
which is basically two characters and
ends with any sequence of characters now
in general we have two different like
operators which is underscore and
percentage Wild Card characters where
underscore matches a single character
and percentage matches 0 or multiple
characters
so the answer to this query is basically
select employee name from employees
where employee name like within the
parenthesis now as I as the question is
stated as it should begin with any two
characters so I can basically put an
underscore here for the first two places
followed by a text which is array and it
can end with any number of characters so
let's say if I have murali whose name
starts with m and the next character is
U so you can take it as m u r a and it
can end with any characters again l i so
murali is an example for this or else
you can take Surat again you can have
two different characters in the first
position and it can end with any number
of characters at the end so this is how
you can use like operator in order to
fetch certain patterns when you are not
aware of the uh you know
string or the data that you are trying
to retrieve from the database table
all right moving ahead let us now
discuss the next question which is
explain what is an alias in SQL and why
we use it now I'm sure you know what uh
the term Alias is it is giving a
temporary name to someone so similarly
in SQL also it is basically a temporary
name that is given to a table or a
column while writing a query now Alias
can be quite useful because let's say if
you're working on a database and if the
columns or the table names are so long
now you have to write or type the
database table again and again in such
long format so instead of that I can
simply write a
Alia's name for that now let's say I
have employee details as my table name
now instead of writing every time
employee details I can just give another
Alias name like EMP or EMP details so
giving aliasis makes the table or column
name more readable as well
now if you are using Alias it is a
temporary change guys so it is just
limited to the runtime of the query
wherein you are executing a query so it
will just give a layer's name for only
that moment and it is not permanently
saved so if you're performing for column
operations the Alias can be used as
select column name as Alias name from
table and if you are giving an arya's
name for table you can write a select
column one or column so on up to n
columns from table name as Alias name
all right let us now discuss the next
question which is explain views in SQL
now a database view in SQL is like
having virtual tables containing a
single query and its result now the
result is usually a work virtual table
which is having the same amount of rows
and columns just like the actual table
so we can either pass a query to store
all the rows and Columns of a table or
just a part of it now the most
significant advantage of using a view in
SQL is that it it also stores the query
and hence we don't write we don't have
to write it again and again from this
scratch but again then the question
arises why not use a stored procedure
instead now even the stored procedures
can hold a query and execute whenever
called however the advantage with views
is that they are easier and more
straightforward compared to procedure
and the query is queries written as
create view view name as select column
one column two up to so on column n from
you can write a single table or from
multiple tables as well you can you all
also use a wire condition
so we can just easily create a view in
SQL from a single table or even multiple
tables using the create view statement
but before anything else we need to
create we need to already have a table
so that we can create a view for it so
that was views in SQL and how they are
used
all right the next question is what are
triggers in SQL
so a trigger is basically a stored
procedure which is a set of SQL
statements saved under a name just like
a function or even when you're writing
you know views which takes a temporary
name so that it can be reused that is uh
triggers can be executed that are
automatically uh you know called on when
there is any change in the database now
for instance you may program a trigger
to execute when data is inserted in a
table now we have different types of
triggers as well based on the event and
the timing of it so we have a different
DML triggers we have ddl triggers and
database triggers so now in DML we have
insert update and delete and in ddl
triggers we can use create an order
statements now the timing is also
important when you are triggering a data
triggering certain event that is you can
use before trigger that is you can use
before insert trigger that is whenever
you're trying to insert a new record if
it is not satisfying the condition that
you have specified then it will omit so
it basically backfires before this
specified event has occurred similarly
you can use after trigger as well which
basically you know fires after a
specified event has already occurred
so that was triggers in SQL
so an immediate following uh question
would be why we use SQL triggers being
an advanced level concept the
interviewer might want to know the
in-depth knowledge of what SQL triggers
are so SQL triggers allows the user to
avoid redundant code with multiple
programs need to perform the same
database operations it also maintains
complex column constraints and refresh
inferential or data integrity and also
it prevents invalid transactions and
make sure that the user that is
authenticating a transaction is being
successfully executed
and finally it increases the performance
of the SQL queries because it does not
need to compile each and every time when
the query is getting executed so there's
those are some of the main reasons why
we use SQL triggers
all right moving ahead let us now
discuss the next question which is what
is indexing in SQL now indexing in X SQL
is a special table used to speed up the
searching process of the data in a
database table now let's say if you're
working on thousands and thousands of
record it becomes quite difficult you
know if you try to retrieve certain data
which are ultimately impacts the
performance of the query now let's say
let's take an example here now you all
might have you know done this in your
school days wherein you have this
textbooks and in textbooks you have
table of contents now if you want to
refer to a particular chapter instead of
searching from page one and
simultaneously moving on to the next
Pages you can just check the index page
where you can find the number now let's
say in the example I want to find the uh
concepts of the neural science of
hospitality which has an index 62. so
instead of searching from the start I
can just turn on to the 60 second page
and just refer to to the contents that
are present in that chapter so similarly
in SQL as well instead of searching
you know the whole table you can just
speed up the process by using an index
so the main benefit of using indexing is
it improves query speed as discussed and
faster data recovery is also another
Factor when using indexing and also it
the efficiency that is the search
efficiency of the query increases
wherein the performance of the database
ultimately impacts on how you are
running the query now the more the com
the more complex the queries the more
you know performance it takes which
ultimately impacts the efficiency so if
you're trying to perform you know data
operations on more than you know 1000
records or let's say one lakh records in
a table in that case you can use index
and that gives us the final question
guys uh which is what are the
applications of SQL in real life
nowadays SQL has been uh in a tremendous
you know usage for more than many
sectors in in real life as well for
example if you take banking banking
sector is an important you know criteria
for our nation for its development so
banking uh uses SQL and it is one of the
major components in banking sector where
Bank stores the account details of
customers and the transaction
transactions done in the database on a
regular basis it is also used in
education sectors like schools and
universities where
the you know users or the people in uh
authorization use SQL and databases to
store and retrieve information about
their students faculty and staff
information
next we have Finance Finance in a is
another massive area where SQL queries
are used regularly in managing the
assets Revenue details shares of the
companies now faster execution and
retrieval of data plays an important
role for all the businesses around the
world to make strategies and derive
insights from it and for that we need
SQL to retrieve the data as early as
possible
and next we have Healthcare again
hospitals and other medical centers use
SQL to store the details of the patients
without any hassle it also helps in
maintaining all the documents necessary
bills as well Etc
manufacturing uh is another important
you know sector where SQL is used and
considering the vast presence in the
market manufacturing also uses SQL in
order to
find the data from the Machinery the
employees that are working in a
particular manufacturing plant and Etc
it is also widely used in travel also in
order to store the details of the
customers let's say if they have any uh
you know offers to be presented in real
time we use SQL in order to store all of
this in no time
and finally we have e-commerce as well
now companies like Amazon Flipkart uh
you know considering its best presence
in the market retail and e-commerce
company stores its customer data to
improve their shopping experience by
providing special offers which in turn
helps the business to grow so these are
some of the uh applications in of SQL in
real life I hope you guys have
understood
and that brings us to the end of today's
tutorial guys I hope you all understood
all the uh SQL interview questions which
are of basic and intermediate level that
are necessary to crack your next
interview
thank you for watching the video guys if
you found this tutorial informative and
helpful give it a thumbs up and share it
with your friends
if you have any further queries
regarding any of the topics covered in
today's session feel free to let us know
in the comment section below and a team
of experts will be more than happy to
help resolve all your queries
at the earliest until next time stay
safe and keep coding
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here